Transcription: Marie Occelli
Relecteur: eric vautier
Il vous plaît, ce T-shirt que j’ai cousu ?
Rouge, rouge TED, si ce n’est pas
de la sérendipité, ça.
Mais parlons d'autre chose.
Qui se souvient de son premier entretien ?
Ça peut être un entretien d’embauche
ou un entretien d’entrée en école.
L'excitation, le stress.
Qui se souvient de la manière
dont il ou elle était habillé ?
OK.
Qui portait un costume ou un tailleur,
par exemple ?
D’accord.
Eh bien, comme la plupart d'entre vous,
je m'en souviens parfaitement.
Je portais un costume, et m’habiller
complètement m’avait bien pris 45 minutes.
Je me sentais étriqué.
J’avais du mal à bouger les bras.
Bouger tout court, en fait.
Sans même me regarder dans un miroir,
je me suis senti différent.
C'était trop sobre, trop conformiste
et pas assez confortable.
Ce sentiment étrange, en fait,
c'était celui du changement.
J’avais tout juste 19 ans,
et enfiler ce costume,
c’était comme faire un premier pas
dans la vie d’adulte.
Réaliser tout cela m’a fait un peu peur
au début, je dois bien l’avouer.
Mais le changement a du bon.
Parce que c'est ça qui nous fait évoluer.
Ce changement peut arriver
à tous les niveaux de l’humanité.
tout au long de notre vie.
Il y a de toutes petites choses.
Même la mode.
Si vous n’en êtes pas encore convaincu,
laissez-moi vous raconter
trois petits épisodes de mode.
Premier épisode.
Un jour, un chasseur rentre
avec une belle prise.
Comme rien ne se perd, on mange la viande,
on récupère la peau
pour se vêtir et se tenir chaud,
on sculpte les os, mais cette fois-ci,
on a l’idée brillante de percer
un petit trou dans un éclat pointu :
l’aiguille est née.
Petite chose, maxi impact.
L’aiguille a permis
à l’humanité de décider
de la forme qu’allaient prendre
ses vêtements, désormais.
Cette innovation a permis à l’humanité
d’explorer le champ des possibles infini
que le vêtement a à offrir.
Bien sûr, avec le temps, l'homme
a perfectionné ses techniques.
L’aiguille est devenue en laiton,
on lui a ajouté un mécanisme
pour créer la machine à coudre.
Autant dire que cette petite trouvaille
a pavé la voie
aux couturiers et aux designers
des siècles à venir.
Le vêtement s’est complexifié à mesure
que l’esprit humain s’est complexifié.
Et l’évolution de la mode va donc de pair
avec l’évolution de l’homme
et de ses découvertes.
Ses découvertes.
Épisode 2.
Maintenant, si vous me demandez
qui est mon modèle ultime de curiosité,
vous savez qui je vous réponds
directement ?
Christophe Colomb.
Sans téléphone satellite, sans GPS,
il a décidé de lever la voile vers l’ouest
et a découvert les Amériques.
De ces contrées lointaines
et mystérieuses,
on a rapporté des choses extraordinaires :
de l’or, du chocolat, la tomate,
mais surtout, on a rapporté
de petites chenilles
qui, écrasées,
produisent un rouge rubis éclatant.
La découverte de ce rouge de cochenille
a profondément transformé
la tenue des élégants de l’époque.
Avoir un manteau,
un vêtement teint à la cochenille
est devenu le signe extérieur de richesse
par excellence à la Renaissance.
Un élément plus précieux
que le velours de Venise,
que l’or, que les perles de Perse.
Pour vous dire, on tue littéralement
à l’époque pour un manteau rouge.
Aujourd’hui,
et heureusement,
vous ne risqueriez plus la prison
pour le T-shirt rouge de votre voisin.
La cochenille a été synthétisée.
Mais le rouge est la conséquence indirecte
de toute l’audace et
de l’esprit d’aventure humain.
Sans l’expédition de Christophe Colomb,
les collections du couturier Valentino
n’auraient jamais été pareilles.
Bon, faisons un petit intermède
dans les épisodes mode.
Vous vous dites sûrement :
« OK, il y a eu d’immenses découvertes,
et je porte parfois
un T-shirt rouge comme lui.
Mais encore ? »
Eh bien,
dans « Le diable s’habille en Prada »,
excellent film de mode
que je vous conseille,
Miranda Priestly dit à cette jeune
novice de la mode qu’est Andrea Sachs :
« Vous portez un vêtement choisi
pour vous,
par les gens qui se trouvent dans ce
bureau, au milieu d’un tas de fringues.
Si vous vous souvenez
de votre premier tailleur ou costume,
je parie que la première fois que vous
l’avez enfilé, vous n’aviez qu’une hâte :
le retirer !
Puis cet habit, vous l’avez porté
une deuxième fois,
une troisième fois,
et la gêne a disparu petit à petit.
La gêne a disparu parce que
votre corps s’est habitué à ce vêtement.
Vous avez commencé à dégager les épaules,
bomber le torse, relever la tête.
Vous avez adopté une posture confiante,
pleine d'assurance.
Cette même posture que requiert le costume
et le tailleur pour être bien porté.
Comme Andrea Sachs dans
« Le diable s’habille en Prada », en fait.
Andrea gagne en assurance et
en crédibilité dans son job,
au fur et à mesure qu’elle
s’approprie les vêtements
et qu’elle s’intéresse à la mode.
Parce que, qu’on se le dise,
ce n’est pas parce qu’elle a enfilé
sa première paire d’escarpins que, pof !
elle est devenue une battante
et a excellé dans son job.
Non, bien loin de là.
Il a fallu qu'elle s'adapte aux vêtements,
qu'elle s'y habitue et qu'elle change.
Comme quoi, le vêtement,
ce n’est pas tellement la question
de comment vous perçoivent les autres.
C’est aussi et surtout ce que vous avez
envie que l’on perçoive de vous.
La mode n’est donc pas
qu’une question d’apparence,
elle change aussi votre façon de penser.
Épisode 3.
Dans les années 60, Mary Quant propose
dans sa boutique de Londres
des jupes à l’ourlet
bien au-dessus du genou.
C’est la mini-jupe.
Dans les journaux de l’époque,
on voit souvent les gens dire
que c’est extrêmement vulgaire
et qu’une dame ne devrait jamais
découvrir ses genoux de la sorte.
Pourtant, la jupe n'a pas été raccourcie
pour faire joli et encore moins sexy.
A l’époque, on arrête encore
les femmes dans la rue
parce qu’elles portent un pantalon.
La mini-jupe possède
cette longueur parfaite,
qui permet de courir
d’une réunion à l’autre,
de conduire une 2 chevaux, une limousine,
en ayant les jambes libres de bouger
comme dans un pantalon.
La mini-jupe, c’est aussi le moment
où les femmes commencent à revendiquer
leur droit à se révolter
contre la société patriarcale.
C'est l'époque des premiers
mouvements féministes.
Porter une mini-jupe,
c’est alors porter ses convictions.
Plus on porte une mini-jupe,
plus on renforce ses convictions,
on les affirme.
La mini-jupe, c’est le changement,
c’est la libération des corps,
mais surtout celle des idées.
Ce vêtement a permis
à des millions de femmes
de se penser autrement ;
de se penser autrement que mère,
fille ou épouse,
de penser, de rêver leur vie différemment.
Le vêtement a donc une incidence directe
sur la façon
dont un individu peut penser,
rêver sa vie.
Ce que vous portez n'est jamais innocent.
La tenue peut être ultra politique,
qu'elle soit républicaine ou pas.
La mode est bien au cœur
des enjeux actuels,
qu’ils soient environnementaux, sociaux.
C’est formidable car
depuis quelques années,
on assiste à un vif engouement
à ce niveau-là.
Depuis quelques années, on assiste
à une révolution créatrice dans la mode.
Durant les trois dernières décennies,
la fast fashion, ou mode de grande
consommation si vous préférez,
n’a cessé de s’étendre.
C'est là que la majorité d'entre vous
a ses petites habitudes, je parie.
Mais quoi qu’on en dise, la fast fashion
est un progrès formidable sur le papier.
Figurez-vous,
il faut imaginer les vêtements,
sourcer les matières, les coudre,
acheminer ça aux quatre coins
du monde toutes les deux semaines.
Mais c’est fou !
Oui, c'est fou.
D’après une étude
de l’ONG britannique Barnardo’s,
ce petit crop top en vichy
bleu ciel tout mignon
que vous avez acheté la semaine dernière,
eh bien, vous ne le porterez
que 7 fois en moyenne.
Génération Z comme zapping.
Parce que le crop top s’abîme, d’une part,
mais surtout parce que
vous vous en lassez.
On a du mal à apprécier
les choses qui durent
et encore moins les vêtements qui durent.
Je pense que ça vient du fait
que l’actualité est plus que morose
et nous empêche parfois d’imaginer ce que
nous serons dans dix ou quinze ans.
Comment alors se résoudre
à investir dans une pièce,
à acheter quelque chose de bonne qualité,
parfois qui coûte de l’argent,
même si cela nous plaît ?
Je ne vais pas
vous jeter la première pierre.
Mais heureusement, la jeune génération est
plus que confiante quant à l’avenir.
Elle recommence à découvrir le potentiel
infini que le vêtement a à offrir.
Vous l’avez peut-être vu,
les comptes Instagram ou Tik Tok dédiés
aux jeunes créateurs et aux tutos couture
fleurissent par centaines chaque jour.
C’est formidable !
Coïncidence ou pas,
mais c’est cette même génération
qui s’engage pour le climat,
l’égalité des sexes, l’égalité tout court.
Et tout cela dans le but de faire
un monde plus juste, un monde meilleur.
Ce que porte cette jeune génération
est le reflet de ses convictions.
Elle véhicule un message.
Si vous ne deviez retenir
ne serait-ce qu’une chose
du petit quart d’heure que
nous avons passé ensemble, c’est ça :
la mode est tout, tout, tout,
tout sauf une chose.
La mode est tout sauf futile.
Encore une fois,
vous vous dites sûrement :
« D’accord,
la mode a changé avec l’humanité.
La mode est tout sauf futile s’il le veut.
Mais moi, dans tout ça ?
En quoi est-ce que ça nous
concerne concrètement ? »
Eh bien...
Vous faites partie de cette humanité.
Votre vie est une petite fraction
d’humanité, si vous y réfléchissez bien.
Et c’est peut-être la plus importante.
Si je vous disais que vous avez changé
en fonction des vêtements que
vous avez choisi de porter,
vous me croiriez ?
Ce sont même eux qui vous ont changé.
La façon dont vous vous habillez
en dit beaucoup sur votre personne.
Cela dit quelque chose sur votre maturité,
sur votre ouverture aux autres.
Le vêtement, c'est du langage non verbal.
Mais cette communication réside bien plus
dans la façon dont vous portez le vêtement
que le vêtement en lui-même.
Tenez !
Après le lycée, je me suis dit
qu’il était peut-être venu temps
de porter autre chose en hiver
qu’un trucker ou qu’une parka.
Je voulais quelque chose de plus habillé,
comme j’entamais
un nouveau chapitre de ma vie.
Et ça a été le coup de foudre
au premier regard.
Il était gris, en laine bouclée,
structuré, construit.
Ce manteau, en un mot, je l’adorais.
Mais malgré mon engouement,
je n’étais pas habitué
à porter ce genre de chose
stricte et construite.
Je me sentais comme déguisé,
quand je l’enfilais,
si vous avez déjà eu cette impression.
En le regardant dans mon armoire,
je me suis dit qu’il était vraiment
dommage d’avoir une si belle pièce
et de ne pas en profiter.
J’ai alors commencé à m’amuser avec,
je l’ai déboutonné, j’en ai fait voler
les pans en marchant.
C’était génial.
C'était flamboyant.
Ce manteau aussi, je le voyais
comme une sorte d’armure
qui me protégeait du monde des adultes
que je venais nouvellement d’intégrer.
Mais l’hiver n’est pas éternel,
et le printemps est arrivé.
Il a donc fallu ranger ce manteau.
Et, miracle ou pas,
je n’ai plus eu besoin de ce manteau,
de cette armure
pour faire croire aux autres
que j’avais confiance en moi.
J’avais intégré tout
ce qu’il m’avait appris,
j’avais retenu les leçons
de toutes les belles histoires
que nous avions vécues ensemble.
Ce manteau, il m'a fait grandir.
Il m’a appris à enlever un vêtement,
à ne pas disparaître derrière lui.
Je suis certain que
vous avez aussi dans votre armoire
ce vêtement que vous regardez
avec tendresse,
qui a une signification
toute particulière pour vous
parce qu’il est le reflet
de votre histoire.
Une ville, un moment de vie,
des rencontres.
Ce que je veux dire par là, c’est : osez,
essayez des vêtements vers lesquels
vous n’iriez pas naturellement,
introduisez de la nouveauté
dans votre garde-robe.
Comme un petit challenge.
Ça peut être une forme,
une couleur différente.
Peut-être que le rouge,
justement, est votre couleur,
qu’il vous donne bonne mine au point
de faire se retourner les gens
sur votre passage et se dire :
« Waouh ! Mais quelle allure ! »
Je l’espère, parce que
j’y ai passé du temps, donc...
Amusez-vous avec les vêtements,
vraiment, le jeu en vaut la chandelle.
Parce que vous évoluerez,
vous découvrirez une nouvelle
facette de votre personnalité.
Vous vous découvrirez un peu plus.
Et on n’a pas besoin d’être
un fanatique de mode
pour s’habiller et consommer comme ça.
Andrea Sachs ne se serait jamais
damnée pour un sac de luxe.
Votre garde-robe, c’est votre histoire.
Donc n’en ayez pas honte.
Même du polaire que vous portiez
toute la journée
lorsque vous aviez sport en 6ème,
même du pull en jacquard acrylique
fluo tricoté par votre grand-mère.
N’en ayez pas honte.
Votre garde-robe, c’est votre histoire.
Une grande histoire à l’échelle
de l’être humain.
(Applaudissements)